hello everybody and welcome to another
money-making guide or maybe I should
call this one a moneys saving guide
because today I'm going to be showing
you how I profited uh while training
magic and crafting I got about 70k magic
experience 70k crafting experience so
about
130 to
150k experience an hour while still
profiting is very good and I'll show you
how I did it all right let's get started
okay so to get the profitable magic and
crafting experience you will need 76
magic and the completion of lunar
diplomacy uh which is a higher level
Quest but really doesn't have that
higher requirements uh you only need
about 1 mil starting cash and uh what
we're going to be doing is using the uh
string or spin flax spell uh it's
actually profitable to cast it as of the
current prices uh but at at worst really
you will be breaking even but right now
it looks like we'll be profiting about
80 coins per cast uh which isn't that
much per hour but when you consider how
much leveling up crafting and Magic
normally costs like you'd be usually
spending at least 500k an hour leveling
your crafting even more depending and
then probably like at least maybe even
500k an hour training your magic if you
want to be somewhat efficient um but
using this spell it'll be profitable you
get about upwards of
75k uh crafting and Magic experience so
150k in total more realistic i al you'll
probably get closer to 60 or
65k um but you can I'll show you in a
second you can get up to 75k if you're
seriously focusing anyway so we have uh
1 mil in the inventory so we're going to
go ahead and buy uh the items we need
for 1 hour of doing this I've calculated
I need about 4,500 flax and we're going
to be kind of lazy here and we're not
going to wait to get the one extra GP on
the flax weird flax is a little more
expensive than I remember anyway and
astral runes we will need about uh
900 900 astral
runes and uh for nature runes we'll need
1,800 okay uh so we're going to collect
all of the ingredients here so that only
costs us about uh 650k so not too much
uh you will just want to wear a staff of
air or any kind of air substitute so you
can see we can use the spin flax spell
and uh yeah so we'll just show you how
it works it's pretty easy to do not
really too much to it deposit the
fls and uh what you need is you want to
obviously keep your runes but you need
one extra item uh I'll just keep the
money here the reason for that is um
when we withdraw the flax so we have a
ton here but we're just going to do
4,500 of it and so when you withdraw the
flax if you have uh three items in your
inventory that will uh give a perfect
ratio uh for the amount of casts you can
do at once cuz each cast gives you turns
five fla into bow strings so we'll go
ahead and just show you here works
really easy you just click wait a second
or two click again and while it's kind
of Click intensive it's not too bad so
you have to do this five times uh the
problem if you only have two items in
your inventory is you will waste the
cast on just one um one flax left
because you have 26 whereas you have 25
is the perfect amount okay so now I'm
just going to prove uh how much
experience per hour you can get if
you're actually focusing uh so we'll
just do this for just like a minute here
withdraw the flax go to your Mage tab
you're just going to click on spin fla
and now you can't you can spam click it
if you want but I prefer to just kind of
get into a rhythm uh the tick is about
one and a half seconds or something like
that and then you're just going to do it
five times there's no point uh checking
your inventory just get used to clicking
it five times banking with drawing the
flax and then it'll toss you right back
into your magic screen and then you can
continue on uh so if we open up our
experience you can see it's upwards of
70 80k right now that'll even back down
two of 75 if you're actually really
focusing that's how much you can get
hourly pretty well uh more realistically
you're going to get closer to 65 or
something like that uh so look I oh no
we're good um but even like small
fuckups like that will reduce your
experience but um you can get upwards of
75 all right so we'll go ahead uh do
this for about an hour or we'll at least
use all the 4500 fls and then we can see
how much money we actually get again
most of the uh oh we just got a crafting
level nice uh most of the benefits of
this method is the money you're saving
the money we're going to earn isn't that
much but when you consider again you
might be saving a mill an hour doing
this over training crafting and Magic
using a more conventional method it's
not too bad so we'll go ahead do this
for about an hour and we'll come back
and see the results all right guys so uh
we're just about to finish up all the
flaxes that we bought now we did manage
to do it a little bit quicker than I
thought you can see uh in the top right
corner here uh the XP gain so far is 61
K and we're getting about 66k in an hour
uh but we are about to finish up all our
runes which means we've done all the
plaques uh so we'll just call it here
that you can get pretty much 65k an hour
uh kind of doing this more a relaxed way
up to 75 if you're really focusing but
this is I when got like a made some
toast and like stop for a second so it's
not this is probably a little more
realistic to how much uh experience you
could expect to get doing a regular
actual uh hour I guess and somehow we
ended up with one extra bit of flax we
got to
do and there we go so we're all done uh
so now we're just going to withdraw the
flax so again it's going to be 45 or the
bow strings sorry again it's going to be
4500 bow strings and we'll go ahead and
sell these now uh we could wait and uh
get the best price possible for it um
but I think we're just well let's check
with bow strings ear see if there's
actually a margin worth waiting for
otherwise I'm just going to instantly
sell them uh so we could sell them for
158 or uh we could uh insta sell them
for
154 okay screw it we'll wait we'll sell
for 158 and we'll come back when they
have
sold all right so the bow string sold
off obviously didn't take very long uh
but we'll go ahead and claim the money
and uh see how much we actually profited
all right so it looks like about 60k in
profit so not a lot but you do have to
keep in mind again that we got 100 30k
experience and it was profitable so when
you think about that that's not too bad
uh cuz often times especially with
crafting if you're crafting battle stabs
you're getting like
150 quite a bit of experience per hour
but it's costing like 2 mil 1 mil an
hour very expensive where uh This Spell
profitable it's a little click intensive
but not too bad same with magic I mean
you can do Break Even methods of
training magic but just the sheer ount
of experience per hour while doing this
not a lot of spells or methods will get
you 100K Plus in an hour without costing
some amount of money so that's what I
really like about this spell and um for
my purposes right now I want to get my
crafting and Magic up so it's pretty
convenient and yeah so I hope you guys
enjoyed the video definitely give it a
try if you have the lunar spell book if
you don't I would recommend getting
lunar uh there's a couple other spells I
want to try on here uh we'll leave that
till next time all right hope you guys
enjoyed the video and I will see you
guys in the next one m
[Music]